protesters in Srinagar throwing stones
the response from Indian security forces
tear gas and pellet guns the protest
began at one mosque where Friday prayers
have taken a defiant tone this month
since the region's autonomy was revoked
by New Delhi it's one of the few ways
locals have to vent their frustrations
restrictions have been imposed on the
use of the internet and mobile phones
and they're finding it difficult to move
around the city and beyond this is a bad
thing for almost three weeks we've been
under restrictions and we're not happy
about it they've torn up our autonomy
and put us on the curfew
no one is going out of the neighborhood
unlike in previous weeks security was
tightened on Fridays to curtail
potential unrest weather restrictions
are eased or re-imposed for Friday
prayers protests have followed and this
time is no exception it's not just
restrictions that's angering locals is a
long-term consequences of the region
losing its autonomy one consequence of
that is that people from outside
indian-administered Kashmir can now buy
property whereas before you had to be a
permanent resident many here worried
that will change the makeup of the
region locusts myths ahead whoa Kashmiri
people would not sell land to outsiders
I don't think but if you see how the
garment Effendi has put us under
military control they might try to make
colonies of outsiders here that would
change the demography of Kashmir that's
what they want some analysts say that's
in line with the government's Hindu
nationalist ideology
falsely erroneous notion which they have
been selling to their people that
Kashmir is the birth place of Hinduism
and we have to reclaim Kashmir what they
will do forcibly it is Gaza type model
forcibly they will make settlements and
Krishna
but Indian government officials say the
removal of Kashmiri autonomy will bring
development to the region but that's not
how many of the people here see the
situation and the protests are likely to
continue as Jamil
al Jazeera Srinagar indian-administered
Kashmir